the beginning of the final regular
season series of the year yankees and
the marlins for three games and the
playoffs start on tuesday marlins are
trying to punch their ticket they could
this weekend the magic number for the
marlins is two
back to back two out walks and the d.h
garrett cooper comes up
eric cooper a former yankee lifts one to
deep right field did he get enough he
did how about that short porch a
three-run homer for garrett cooper and
it's a three-nothing marlins lead
up up and away a long home run for
garrett cooper and a three to nothing
lead for the marlins here in the first
inning at yankee stadium here is aaron
judge here's a 3-2 pitch
that is a called strike three looked
like a strike most of the way there and
then dipped out of the strike zone and i
think you can hear some grunting from
the yankee dugout two outs for aaron
hicks who takes a strike that one at 97
from sandy
i think it's with the judge judge is
getting killed with those aaron boone
certainly not thrilled with the strike
zone early on so aaron very early in
this game really upset with the played
umpires strikes on
and went after jontom payne and got
ejected the mayhew works a walk and that
brings up judge
that one is ripped down the left field
lineup bullet into the corner and up
against the wall lumayou is at third
they're gonna hold him right there
and a double for aaron judge but that's
an aggressive swing and that's what you
want to see out of aaron judge over the
weekend so second and third with two
outs and here is aaron hicks
line drive a base hit down the right
field line
that'll score two and hicks is at second
with a two-run double so the yank aarons
do it a double by judge a double by
hicks and it's now 3-2 marlins a two-run
double for aaron hicks
and the yankees now trail three to two
contra in search of win number four in
his final regular season start tonight
they'll get giovanni rashela to the
plate 2-2 pitch swinging a miss he
strikes out her shallow that's five case
for alcontra
he's got nursela both times sandy
alcantara back to work will face aaron
judge
their strike three called on aaron judge
and strikeout number seven for sandy
alcatra who leads this game
stanton of the plate a couple of
strikeouts tonight
another strikeout of stanton third time
tonight eighth in the game
starling martay with bertie at first
base we'll see in a 3-2 game if john
bertie wants to run here bertie a bluff
and this one chopped to
torres it's short
and it pulls voight off the back so
martay
with that speed puts pressure and look
who gets to third is john bertie yeah of
course he did because he didn't stop
running
now with two outs that's how you have to
think as a base runner you continue to
put pressure on the defense and bernie
does a fantastic job here's augie law
well they don't get the chance as that
one's popped up
and le mayo makes the play
and that will do it no runs no hits two
errors and two men left on base bottom
of the eighth marlins three yankees two
beautiful pitching performance tonight
so far for sandy alcantara back to work
2-2 runner goes throw from wallach is
not in time and
just able to keep the toe on the bag
mike talkman watch to payne who's behind
home plate wallach knocks him with the
elbow right in the mask interference on
the homeplate umpire which i'm guessing
is a dead ball he's gonna have to go
back to first that is a horrible break
for the yankees they had the base stolen
and now frazier strikes out and there
goes the bat don't try that at home kids
that's uh you're gonna hurt your leg
so here is aaron judge big spot for the
yankee right fielder
looped into right field coming on
brinson he can't make the play and that
is going to tie the score
so judge with a big hit and the game is
knotted at three
one out harrison now at third base and
starling martay and he is due
ground ball
and now they've got harrison in between
third and home he's just inching toward
home plate he got shioka runs it back to
third it goes off harrison and he's back
to third
and martay moved to second in the
rundown
second and third now for the runners
look at this
i like monte in the middle of that
rundown just discarding the helmet i
don't need this anymore he just chucked
his helmet off into foul territory now
aguilar in a huge spot a 1-2 from green
is lifted will it be deep enough oh i
think so on the edge of the track judge
makes the catch here comes the throw
not in time harrison scores the marlins
take a 4-3 lead they started the night
with a magic number of two the phillies
fell at the trop tonight so that magic
number trimmed to one and the bases will
be loaded for la mayhew one two
chopped up the middle
rojas
there it is
and for the first time in 17 years the
marlins are going to the postseason